yeah welcome to this blitz game playing
yeah probably not and Ray guessing but
he's got very high rating it's no name
and um ok only the Russian flag came
let's play this and let's hope I am
don't jump from get all my lines that I
had discussed in this video serious now
i'm actually out of on my owner already
yep not sure what I had to recommend it
here Bishop to d7 hmm I'm not sure I
can't play me six maybe okay anyway not
sure that this is so terrible maybe it
is
okay the play Knight f6 here normal then
after rookie one or something he yeah I
think I need to act win h5 yeah it's
probably still I'm still not so bad
because I'm winning maybe some time on
the queen with Queen B 8 or something
it's just a way to return the pawn 26
yeah let's do that the double porn if he
takes he won't take this really helps me
yeah so maybe take
I'm not recapturing maybe for some new
vodka okay let's see what happens rocks
yet is Sam may be a bit passive not sure
I want to play quick Bishop g7 97 then I
really should be okay here
my bone structure slightly worse but
don't think it's so so bad let's get
scheduled of this tonight if he moves it
I probably can really take see form it's
a terrible structure but yeah on this
one I see yeah okay but look I've age
it's a temple at least and if I grab on
e5 and rook f5 it's got look at you one
at the end takes tags who came so
probably this one keeping the pressure
on here the rook is ok on the fifth
covering everything ok 93 or don't
really get it at the moment ok let's
take this first
don't really understand the move Knight
to Bishop Bishop d6 or something hmm
yeah but this isn't the end of the world
interesting not sure looked upon we
wasn't sure what is sown thinking about
okay Bishop especially six really a
threat or something night III is also
possible
I g'nite be six maybe Knight b6 Bishop
d6 I can retreat you too okay
complicated I'm 93 I wanted to stack the
exchange not sure it's really great but
I already have a pawn so yeah or is
there some other move I know this was
the plan this was the plan all along so
no this one its default this was my DM
because I'm attacking yeah I'm attacking
see for now and I'm not sure how he
covers it this should be for Nazi form
what wait what about 86 can I just go a
six-year trying to put this night off
side so that it cannot even go to be
five hmm I didn't see that move coming
look we ate it just nonsense shoot
ah what a shame i will look at that one
anyway maybe I can do that anyway rupee
one Bishop before nights II to Queen
Bishop to Knight takes e4 maybe cannot
really calculate this the other stuff
looked too bleak first this one yeah I
can do that let's try to expel 96
wait wait why did I take it I hope you
fall I take esox is going knight c6
m.o.b 798
check
yeah very strong yeah it's got rookie 5
no no b5 and this is of course so this
is enough as well all right yeah well
he's no police no pets and even even if
I i'm pretty sure i had a very good
position to have to be honest but i
didn't i didn't really I couldn't
Kentucky late this properly here yeah
not too surprisingly this is very much
better for black button I overlooked
rookie 6 this is really matter of
precise calculation Bishop f5 is very
good for black not that I understand why
there should be five
now probably to that night to be five is
not a temple but this is a really weird
move this is still an edge for black but
not so clear poor wait this is this is
right actually I cannot play that the
compliments to play a five and cause
this draw and cool this it says this
this should be a draw really 000 like
pawns are promoting it as possible
oopsie 692 and this is the draw
according to the comp yeah I was pretty
sure that was something but how can us
should i played this with one minute on
the clock my problem was what I saw I
saw this and I wanted to take his six of
course but this is not only because yeah
even this but this is good enough I have
no square this is yang just an ugly [ __ ]
and this is winning now of course
nothing nothing I can do I must play 53
the only move this even it's not clear
yeah yeah here to calculate correctly
here even if it was a good position yeah
but an interesting game thanks for
watching